[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
good evening
hi all of you who are for the record
here on time
gold star for each of you my name is
karen miner so glad you're here so glad
you're joining us online as well welcome
to the table
i have just a couple of announcements to
get us started things that are happening
tonight and then things that are kicking
off next week let's start with tonight
does anybody know what day it is
april 3rd
and which sunday of the month is it
first sunday thank you yes
tonight is first sunday so as tradition
goes around here we're going to be
participating in communion which we've
been doing every sunday during lent
we will be doing that again tonight and
then immediately after the service we
are going to take the party over to hack
creek burger company in saxxy just down
the road for dinner together so all of
you are invited
so make sure to join us for that it's
just a fun time to continue
conversations there's only so much
we can pack in before and after the
service as far as personal connection
and conversations so we like to at least
once a month
allow for a little extra time for
community and getting to know each other
so we'll do that tonight
then next week starts holy week
and that includes palm sunday good
friday and then of course easter so palm
sunday is one week from tonight we have
something special planned we're not
going to tell you right now
but you'll want to be here for it that's
next sunday here at pleasant valley
then that following friday is good
friday we'll have a good friday service
we'll join in with pleasant valley with
their congregation we'll have a service
that will be together with them which i
always love i love just gathering
together with other
churches and communities and they're
like extended family to us so
good friday service will be that friday
before easter 7 pm
7 p.m right here and then two days later
sunday is easter
and that will not be here and it will
not be in the evening so please make a
big mental note about that or put it in
your phone to remember we won't be here
we will be up the road at blue heron
event center we'll send out all that
information before before easter sunday
so you'll have that
but that service is in the morning 10 30
10 30. 10 30 a.m okay
please invite
friends family members neighbors easter
is just one of those times where people
are more open to attend church and it's
going to be a beautiful service lots of
fun stuff for the kids including a
petting zoo and like stuff we don't get
here
so
it'll just be a really really wonderful
time of being together and
centering on jesus as we always do
around here so
as we get ready to enter into musical
worship let's take a moment to also
just center our minds and our bodies
everybody you know walking in you've had
other things going on today this past
week
some great maybe some not so great but
you're here
so let's let's mark that just close your
eyes bow your head take a deep breath in
exhale
just take a moment to be
to remember that you are enough
just right here as you are you don't
have to do anything
you don't have to strive
you don't have to look good you don't
have to perform
you're here
god loves you
we love you
so god we center on those truths tonight
that you are here
you are love
you are peace you are the source of hope
no matter what we're going through
and we can center on that and that
center will hold no matter what else is
swirling around us
so god we give you tonight
we surrender ourselves to you
i pray that we're able to do that at
deeper and deeper levels
that we can trust you god
that you are faithful
that all although things are not always
good around us or within us you are good
god so we invite you in
invite you into our hearts our minds
help us to center on your truth and your
love and your goodness tonight
in jesus name amen
amen
thanks karen why don't you guys stand
with us we're going to get started in
this worship set and um i was thinking
about this yoga practice that we used to
go through
um once upon a time and like i don't
know if you've been in a yoga class but
this instructor would have us tighten
like every muscle of your body and she
would like go through you know from head
to toe like tight and tight tight knot
and then like one by one like let go of
this then let go of this that's what
just came to my mind as karen was like
preparing us and i hope that this set
feels like that too because we keep our
guard up so much you know throughout our
lives through throughout our weeks
and some for necessary reasons and
others just because of habit or you know
about experiences but i hope you can let
your guard down in this set and just
feel jesus's presence because he is with
us he is with us he is with us he is
with us
you know let that just wash over you as
you enter in
all right mel's gonna get us started
[Music]
amen
hope
falling down like great love
like i can't explain peace
[Music]
feels like
where the spirit of the lord is there
[Music]
where is spirit of the lord is there is
freedom
i am free angry
[Music]
praise god
who saved my life
[Music]
amen
where the spirit of the lord is there is
freedom
by everyday
[Music]
cause i'm free at last
thank god almighty i am free at last
come on i'm free at last
[Music]
i am
thank god almighty
[Music]
thank god
i am
[Music]
there is freedom
i am free amen
where the spirit of the lord is
there is freedom
i am
[Music]
all right well you guys read along as we
enter into the prayer of the people and
if you're online we encourage you to
engage by leaving a comment in that
section
for the city of saxi texas and for every
city and community and all of those who
live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
for the old and the sick
for the widow and the orphan for the
injured and suffering we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute
for prisoners and captives and for all
who remember and care for them
we pray to you
lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us and so now we lift these
names and situations up to you
nana
from online
please lift up larry
[Music]
students at school
and some people dealing with mental
health issues
from online
please lift up raquel nelson
for the names and moments that we've
spoken aloud and for those that we kept
in our hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light
healing and hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
i lose my ability
to be afraid when i
see the way you
love me
and all the fear that held my
feet to the floor
you don't hold me anymore
when i
see your face
[Music]
and everything changes the
radius of your smiles
[Music]
you've got this way of
chasing away those
[Music]
i'm out
just who
i
am
[Music]
hear you say my name
and all the voices that once
filled my head
[Music]
when everything changes
lord i fall down again
i'm finding out just
[Music]
lord i fall
down again
i'm finding love
just who
i am
[Music]
hopelessness
is
[Music]
do you have found me on my knees
changes in the
radiance of your smile
[Music]
you've got this way of
chasing away those
shadows that hang around
[Music]
and everything changes in the
radiance of your smile
[Music]
you got this way of
chasing away those
shadows
[Music]
in
fall
down again
i'm finding out just who
i am
[Music]
i've waited for this moment
is
[Music]
so
good
he's so
to
me
he
died for me
he's so
good
to me
he
loves me
[Music]
he
loves me so
[Music]
so
good
is
[Music]
jesus we just want to let that truth
sink into our hearts into our bones into
the way that we live
that you're a good god that is for us
and that you created our inmost being
that you hemmed us in
before and behind
that you know us
and you see us
when we soar on the heights or when we
make our bed in the pit you are there
you are with us
emmanuel
would we believe that you are a god who
walks through fire with us who sees us
in our darkest ugliest
worst moments and says i'm doing a new
work in you
i am the one who made you i am the one
who knows you and calls you my own
god would we begin to live differently
because we belong to a god who loved us
so much that he would die
a god who saw us before the beginning of
time and said you are my prize you are
my beloved you are my son and my
daughter you are my child
god would we live as your children
beloved
belonging to someone
not as orphans
not as slaves
but as children of god
who can approach your throne with
boldness with confidence with belonging
[Music]
god my heart is so
grateful for the people in this room and
the way that you made them and call them
your own
god would it sink into us
would it change the way the way we
relate to one another and the world
around us
would it change us from the inside out
even the way that we see ourselves the
person we see in the mirror
would we love them the way that you have
[Music]
thank you for this time together thank
you for moments where we get to let it
go and let our guard down and enter into
a creative and beautiful space
god that's a gift
it's such a gift to spend time with
these people in this room in this moment
help us to be present here to hear what
you have for us
as brett comes to share god with our
hearts be receptive and open
would we be able to receive all that you
have
it's in your name i pray
amen
thank you guys so much you can be seated
and would you turn to the people around
you
help them to feel welcome and wanted
here as brett comes to get ready for the
message
well good evening
grace and peace
it is great to be with you it's really
good to be um
back some of you know i was uh i was not
here last sunday
and i was doing some uh
some ministry uh
in the mountains of colorado skiing i
don't know
some soul care
which we'll get to it's actually the
title of the message tonight um
but it was it was yeah good rest but i'm
really glad to be back and um
i know uh the reverend denise mason uh
preached for me and she's great right
for those who are here she's wonderful
if that was your first time to hear
pastor denise then you're that was a
treat
she really has um just such a gift gift
for um even beyond her writing and
communication skills which are you know
fairly obvious but just her soul her
spirit it's just life-giving so
uh
denise if you happen to be listening to
this at some point
love you lots so grateful for you thank
you for investing in this this community
so
um all right well i want to give a warm
welcome to all of you um but that of
course includes those joining us online
love you lots and uh and anyone here
who's new kind of making their way into
the community thank you for um joining
us tonight so um we are in it's not i
don't know if it's really a series the i
mean the series is titled lent at the
table but
really it's kind of a season um in the
christian calendar um where we are um
just kind of joining in with a broader
church in a time of preparation as we as
karen was talking about earlier kind of
approach um you know palm sunday and
good friday and easter so it's um really
a time of a lot of focus on discipleship
you know who who are we in relationship
or in relation to christ and what does
it mean for us to live and move to the
world
differently
as
christians so that's really kind of the
focus of this of this series and so like
i mentioned the
title of my message is soul care and
we're going to be in john chapter 12
verses 1 through 8 tonight it's just a
short little story
which is really interesting so we're
going to go ahead and if you can read
that with me either in your bibles or of
course as always it is on the screen
so
the story goes like this six days before
the passover
jesus came to bethany where lazarus
lived whom jesus had raised from the
dead uh if you're familiar with um the
gospels you know this is a place where
jesus went a lot it seems to be uh these
were his friends um this uh brother and
two sisters lazarus and then martha and
mary so you'll notice throughout the
gospel story he's often kind of
retreating to bethany when he needs
some rest so
where lazarus lived whom jesus had
raised from the dead verse 2 here a
dinner was given in jesus honor
martha served while lazarus was among
those reclining at the table with him
then mary took about a pint of pure nard
an expensive perfume she poured it on
jesus's feet and wiped his feet with her
hair and the house was filled with the
fragrance of the perfume but one of his
disciples judas iscariot who was later
to betray him objected why wasn't this
perfume sold and the money given to the
poor it was worth a year's wages
and then john has this little aside
he did not say this because he cared
about the poor but because he was a
thief
as keeper of the money bag he used to
help himself to what was put into it so
he's got his little little backstory
verse seven
leave her alone
jesus replied
it was intended that she should save
this perfume for the day of my burial
you will always have the poor among you
you will not always have
me
so this text it's uh i'd say it's a it's
a rich one you know it's like there's a
lot
um a lot going on plenty to delight and
disturb us there's the uh the
fascinating background with um on judas
which as i don't recall i don't think
any of the other gospels like mention
this kind of background about him um not
only being the keeper the money bag but
like you know uh stealing from it so uh
we've got that kind of background on
judas we've got lazarus there
who the text mentions jesus had just
some time before had raised from the
dead
uh so he's an interesting character and
there he is and then got the two sisters
uh martha
of course serving um
and then mary reclining at jesus
specifically names that she's letting
down her hair even our culture this
would be a kind of a scandalous moment
or you know kind of just like oh a
little un socially uncomfortable you
know like what's going on right now now
you can imagine i mean two thousand
years ago with all of its you know sort
of cultural norms and
much more strict and i mean in that
culture this is like what is going on so
you've got mary you know letting down
her hair perfuming jesus feet um but
it's interesting the way jesus
interprets it right is in light of his
crucifixion which is to come which kind
of casts a whole drama on the moment
because it's really kind of a transition
it's like a build up to
what's coming good friday right the
crucifixion
and then kind of layered on top of that
you have not only all those relational
dynamics um between like judas jesus
between martha mary but then you kind of
layer on this like theological kind of
argument discussion around well should
this act have even been done i mean it
says it's a year's wages so you kind of
translate that from then to now we're
talking like 10 20 30 000
perfume
that i mean it does it's just this
lavish act of worship and adoration and
uh it's a lots a lot of money though it
could help a lot of people and so we can
kind of quibble as john does with
judas's motives and yet i think i don't
know if when you heard the story maybe
you were thinking like oh wow that is a
lot though i mean judas has a point
and i mean i'm just imagining we had our
state of the table meeting you know a
few weeks back kind of our church family
business meeting and uh i'm just
imagining if at the next one i'm like
hey great news we've had a j it's a
gigantic donation from an anonymous
donor twenty thousand dollars to the
table oh my gosh i'm like and i've got
an idea we're gonna hire a jeweler and
create this giant golden cross
and just imagine every sunday you get to
come here and like have the
giant golden cross you know
i'm pretty sure y'all be like
i don't know man i don't know if that's
really the best thing like me i mean
that's i guess it's nice but
maybe you split it up for some i don't
know just a better use of the money
right so even i think in our in our
bones even if we want to quibble with
judas again
we're kind of like yeah but he does have
a point so
you can kind of see this is like all
it's just all swirling around the story
lots going on it's quite emotionally
charged relationally charged
theologically church just a lot going on
and um so it got me to thinking like
what's the essence of this thing what's
you know what's going on here
and um of course there's many slants and
takes on this on the story but um what
kind of came to me is i think um
the reason it's resonated with so many
generations um is because it's naming a
certain tension
that we all
um kind of live in it's it's a tension
between what we might call uh like the
practical on the one hand you know just
our yearning for like we gotta just do
stuff we gotta live in practical ways
and yet at the same time we have this
deep longing for beauty
you know it's like for the lavish for
the extravagant for the just you know
you like splurge and just have the huge
just amazing meal or whatever you know
it's like this doesn't make any sense we
really shouldn't be going here but
it's the big day or it's whatever and so
we just sort of go for it right and it's
like this tension that we kind of live
in between like well it's not really
practical it's like the practical and
the beautiful um or what we might call
the tension between
action a life of action and
contemplation
um a tension between um service
and a yearning for worship
right and it's sort of this it's like
this story just goes right right into um
the the tension here and um if you're
familiar at all with like other um
stories in the gospels matthew mark
lujan then you know there's another
story on this one in luke chapter 10
where it's like very similar um you've
got again martha serving and again
mary
this time not doing the whole perfume
thing but just it's the story goes that
she's just reclining there at the table
with jesus he's speaking she's just
drinking in like his words
and
martha's in the kitchen like doing all
the stuff
you know what i mean like getting stuff
done
yeah like that's beautiful right and so
and she gets a little frustrated so she
goes jesus it's like hey can you please
tell her to get up and help me
and
if you're familiar with the story you
know jesus again has this sort of
strange response where he's like no
like what he's like actually martha he
says martha martha you are
busy and you're worried about so many
things
but but you've like forgotten the most
important thing actually mary has chosen
what is better
again can you hear can you feel the
tension in that like i mean why because
like serving others that's like a very
christian thing
right like that's a value in the kingdom
of god sir
i mean it's jesus who said like i come
among you as the what
servant of all like
this is no jesus you're supposed to say
is you are correct martha mary get off
your booty and get in there and and you
know like
but he doesn't
he's like no actually and then again
here we are john chapter 12
similar story and it's about this money
and all and again it's like we have this
value for the poor helping the poor
again this is like goes right to the
heart of the christian faith right
matthew 25 the the least of these you
know and there i was hiding you thought
it was just the the
naked person or the destitute person or
the sick person or the person in prison
but the whole time it was me
and so when you know what you did to the
least of these my brothers or sisters
you did unto me like this is jesus own
words and so again we would read this
story
and expect he's like you're right
this is too extravagant
and yet he's
he again says no actually
just like in luke chapter 10 here we are
john chapter 12.
mary discerned the better
thing
she was in the moment and she like
knew what to do
and she was right
even when everything in us says
i don't know
what is going on in this story there's
uh i want to come at this sideways
there's um
like this old i don't know probably in
college they would call it a narrative
trope
it's like a recurring theme in stories
that you know the story is always
different but like it's really the same
story you know it's sort of just the
characters are different it's different
setting but it's like the same story and
there's this uh this old narrative i was
thinking like which um
stories have i seen it in just in film
um just in the pixar world this is like
three different stories it's um the
narrative arc of like up
um
it's the story of cars 3
it's the story of toy story 3 with that
terrible bear lotso
um
now again all different stories
but like
there's a thread through it that's like
a very similar story and so um
kind of zooming out i'll give you like
this the story okay
so there's uh
there's an old
we'll go with man it's an old man
and he is uh
a curmudgeon
just a curmudgeon like just bitter
he doesn't want to help anyone
with anything
then
entering our story is our hero our
protagonist
and she is like the opposite
she is young
she is vibrant
she like whereas the old man had this
frown etched permanently onto his face
just never smiles
she's like the opposite this smile is
just light of her face she is young she
is idealistic she is passionate
she is like she she wants she just wants
to help people she just wants to make a
difference in the world she wants to
love
like just she's just wonderful and of
course in the story what happens they
meet
right they they connect with one another
and
she maybe like goes it's always kind of
a different way but somehow they have to
like connect and then she has to like
kind of start getting into his life a
little bit right they kind of have to
become friends even though the whole
time he's like uh i don't want any
friends you know but she's like starting
to relate you know and so maybe like in
one story it might be that she goes in
his house and there's pictures on the
walls
you know it's the story of his life and
she asked what oh who is this and he of
course the first time shuts her down i
don't want to talk about that you know
but she week after week goes by month
after month she keeps asking questions
and slowly what happens
slowly yeah the story it starts to
tumble out
and and what's the twist
the twist is always that that old man
that this curmudgeon
bitter
unforgiving i don't want to help anyone
like he used to be
a much younger man
and only now you might think well he was
young and then he was still like that
but that's the twist
no
all right he when he was younger who was
he
he was young and idealistic
and passionate he just wanted to make a
difference in the world right and of
course again the story is always
slightly different but it's like the
same story so
sometimes it's that um his but his sweet
heart died
and then he got cold on the inside or or
sometimes it's that he had someone um
that he thought he could trust
and he couldn't trust them they'd
betrayed him uh sometimes it's just that
like he wanted to make a difference in
the world
and he got out there and was trying
and it just all like went to crap it
just
nothing good happened quite the opposite
like the very people he's trying to help
like hurt him
and
and so of course there the story all
tumbles out and they're relating
relating
but what happens through the relating
that old man
like starts to see
a much younger version of himself in
this young girl
and in the relating
this cold
heart of stone what happens it starts to
thaw
and by the end of
the novel or the movie or
up or whatever the story is you know
what what's happened the old man has
found his smile again
has been redeemed
right and now this story plays out over
and over and over and we'll sit there
and we know what's happening
like we're watching it we're like yeah
i've seen this before it's like last
night it was with cars and now it's like
with balloons you know but it's like the
same story and yet we'll sit there and
we'll eat it up and soak it up like yes
this is so good why
i think i think some of it's because we
see
we probably well if you've lived enough
life to get at least a little bit
jaded or hurt or wounded you know you
kind of see
yourself in like both of those
characters
but i think it's also that even though
it can be a little bit perhaps cliche
it's cliche because it's true
and i think the truth
that that story is getting at is its
naming
that contrary to what we might think
um sometimes
the
the most bitter among us
is bitter
precisely because they used to be the
most open-hearted
among us
and it was that open-heartedness
that made them vulnerable
and they got hurt like that's the wisdom
of the story right because it's easy to
kind of judge like oh that preserves a
conversion they're terrible i bet
they're always like that but that's the
wisdom of the story he's like no no no
no
no no no no
sometimes the most bitter among us they
used to be the most open-hearted among
us
and sometimes
like the very person who says i don't
want to help anyone with anything
like used to 5 10 15 20 years ago
like were what in our society we call a
helper
like they were
a therapist
they were
a volunteer
they were i mean all the things right a
teacher a principal an activist uh maybe
like they were a pillar in the church
you know like they were a first
responder and what happened they put
themselves out there day after day after
day after day they poured they gave of
themselves and then what happened then
they got hurt in the process
right this is
this is what just blows my mind like
the fact that like well i'll just phrase
it like this isn't it remarkable
that we can be um how do i put it like
basically doing a thing
and forget why on earth we began doing
that thing in the first place
isn't it remarkable that we can like set
out to serve people in whatever capacity
and then come to resent the very people
we set out to serve
like isn't it remarkable that sometimes
the worst among us
used to be the best
among us
but it's a cold hard world out there
you see um
i think jesus and the christian saints
down to the centuries i think they see
farther
than we do it's like we're on a path and
we just we're shrouded and missed we
can't see where it's going we just can't
see
but like they see
and
the way ancient christians interpreted
this text was they said um martha and
jude is kind of even in his own way
perhaps um they are like they're a
symbol
of a certain type of person
they're kind of the old man
the person who they
they they wanted to help they wanted to
serve they want to put themselves out
there
and they did and they gave and they gave
and they gave but somewhere along the
way
they got hurt
disappointed jaded confused
they forgot why the heck they even
started doing this in the first place
like they just lost
true north
they just lost it
and in that process
um
they
slowly well the way the bible put it is
they lost as a book of revelation they
lost their first love
that's what happened they lost their
first love here's kind of what i'm
driving at
um
if i and i think we all do if i travel
the path
of action and service
without time without space
for um
contemplation and worship
my destination will pretty much
inevitably be burn out in bitterness
i think that's the wisdom of specific to
this story if i travel the path of
action and service without this time and
space for contemplation and worship my
destination will be burned out in
bitterness
because
some of our greatest minds in the
christian faith they also said that mary
is a symbol
not of a lazy person
mary's a symbol of someone who did
not leave her first love
who stayed centered
on christ who
who remained in the moment
and could discern
when it was time to work
and when it was time to rest
when it was time for service and giving
giving giving giving and when it was
time to say
no more
right when it was time to give and when
it was time to receive
now just to be clear this isn't about um
like
choosing
which one's better
you know um instead what i want to
really advocate for tonight is us
bringing them together
martha and mary
it's not either or
right it's there's a sense of both and
this is where if you're familiar with
the writings of richard rohr who i
really appreciate so much of what he's
written but his his little organization
the center for contemplation and action
well named
right he's it's it's bringing them
together
now this word contemplation can be a
little bit uh i don't know a little
fuafua so you might be wondering what do
you what do you mean contemplation you
just sit around contemplating things
here's what i mean by contemplation
slowing the heck down
nourishing your soul nurturing your
connection to god
that's what i mean
slowing down
nourishing your soul nurturing your
connection to god i think that looks a
lot of different ways it looks like um
coming here tonight worship
looks like worship not only through
music
but there's something i think really
significant about gathering and like
getting quiet perhaps for some of you
this is like the only time in your week
that there's like a little bit of
you know you kind of know what i'm
talking about
it's like just
like
we need that
we need that it's gonna be about worship
um
it can be contemplation can look like um
scripture
you know just taking time to like not
just read the bible like i've got my one
year bible reading plan i've got to get
through this you know but like to so can
it
take some time take some space like even
60 seconds
can be like something if you can slow
down
not be quite so goal-oriented which is
strange how we kind of carry that same
passion for productivity and efficiency
into our spirituality which just doesn't
quite work god moves and the soul kind
of moves at its own pace you know
and we have to come into alignment with
that i think there's something beautiful
about soaking in scripture just
let it see yourself in the story
let god speak
um it can look like a prayer
i mentioned these three because these
are i would say like the basics of
course there's many ways people
reconnect and nourish their souls and
connect with god and i mean thousands
but i'd say these are like the basics
that we never leave behind you know
prayer
just can be silence it can be just
speaking honestly to god i love the idea
of just holding up my burdens to god
people situations and just like
here you go
i don't know how to deal
just
oh god just unburdening that's
can you see how if especially as
christians right who is because we have
those values for helping serving giving
laying down our lives trying real hard
for god you know that's kind of how it
can end up kind of weirdly getting
twisted like where it's not so much
about worship anymore it's just about
trying hard for god i hope he accepts me
you know something that's such a strange
theology but that's where it kind of
goes and we've got to stay centered
like okay god
help even my service being act of of
worship
i'm going to close with this story
there's a
woman her name was fannie lou
hamer and she was um really one of the
most significant voices although she's
somewhat um not not well known but one
of the most significant voices in the
civil rights
movement in the 1960s
a wonderful wonderful woman she uh grew
up in mississippi
um she was the child of sharecroppers
and early in her life that's what she
did or even into early adulthood um was
a sharecropper so just work in the land
through a series of circumstances though
she um had a local activist who
basically encouraged her to
um get registered to vote
and she didn't even know that was a
thing and this kind of stirred a
lifelong passion for her to help
um
her own african-american community um
registered to vote so she shifted from a
sharecropper to an activist she traveled
primarily in mississippi but really all
over southern states um helping
people learn to
how to how to register and then how to
go and vote
and as you can imagine you know in the
1950s 60s uh this is not a popular
profession she was um brutally
beaten assaulted
um falsely imprisoned
i mean her life was really in constant
danger
and um there's been a biography written
about her titled walk with me
and that title is taken from a key
moment in her life
where she was in a winona mississippi
jail june 1963.
she'd been falsely in prison they then
the guards proceeded to beat her with an
inch of her life she was literally she
said she was laying on the on the in the
cell floor she couldn't get up she tried
to get up she couldn't get up and she
had the thought in her mind like this
this might be it i might i might not
make it and she um just whispered to her
cellmate who was also a fellow activist
euvester simpson she said um
i need you to sing
with me
sing with me because i'm i'm not sure
i'm gonna make it and i need to know
that god is with me
see fannie lou hamer was a christian um
pretty much her whole life in singing in
fact you go on google images and look up
images
almost all of them are her singing she
would
lead people in
worship and song she saw it as so
integral to her work so she said you
vester i need you to sing
and so yvester started to sing the song
walk with me lord
walk with me
and
vinnie lou said that as as she sang that
it was like she got this sense
that someone bigger than her was with
her
and she woke up the next morning and
walked out of
that prison
i think that's a beautiful image because
of someone who is both martha and mary
right her life she was committed to the
work
giving her life on behalf of others i
mean she's about as martha as it comes
like busy yep real busy
and yet at the same time
had the spirit of mary
the spirit of worship and prayer and
song and because i mean it's a it's a
remarkable thing to live like through
what she lived through and not become as
we talked about earlier the old man
right the burnt out
bitter just eaten up with rage
how did she do it
she didn't forget her first love
she she had the spirit of martha and
mary she brought them together
and so as we come to the table of the
lord today i want it i want us to come
in that same spirit of it's a moment of
contemplation it's a moment of
reconnection of re-centering on
the broken body
of christ symbolized in the bread the
blood of christ symbolized in the wine
and it's this moment of yes god help me
re-center
reconnect with you and then may this act
of spiritual nourishment may it send us
out those doors
into the world
in that spirit of martha ready to serve
ready to give
so
let me invite you to the table with
these words
this is the table
not of the church
but of the lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more
so come
you who have much faith in you who have
little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long
you who have tried to follow and you who
have failed come
come because it's the lord himself who
invites you
and it is his will that those who want
to meet him should meet him here
come to the table
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
foreign
so
we wanted to close out with that
same hymn that um
the cellmate sing with fanny
that night so if you guys would join us
let's stand together
and sing through this
you may not know it at first but it's
kind of repetitive so if you can just
join in as as it becomes more familiar
and let's just sing this
over ourselves and each other all right
walk with me
lord
[Music]
walk with me
walk with me lord
god walk with me
while i'm on this old
tedious journey
i want jesus
walk with me
take my hand
lord
take my hand lord
take my hand
[Music]
while i'm on this
old tedious journey
i want jesus
[Music]
don't want is
walk with me
lord
while i'm
on tedious
journey
i want jesus
walk with me
so glad you were all here tonight
here and online
having you here makes this a better
community it just does each of you add
something
uh to this community some things to keep
in mind don't forget tonight is first
sunday we are headed over to hat creek
burger company just up the road on 78
and woodbridge road
to gather for dinner
if if finances are a challenge for you
right now don't let that be a barrier
come see me come see brett we'll make
sure your meal is paid for tonight we
just want you there
um
also don't forget about palm sunday next
sunday it's gonna be a special surprise
so just make sure you're here that's all
i'm going to say
also if you are new or newish and would
like to get connected we would like to
get to know more about you and your
story we have visitor cards out on the
itty bitty table right outside this back
door fill that out with your name and
contact information drop it in the box
we'll get in contact with you online
leave a comment
and we'll get in contact with you as
well
also if the values and the mission and
what we're about here at the table
resonates with you we do encourage you
to give
it helps our community to keep on going
and one of the reasons why i give
personally to the table is that there's
a quote that i
love it says every time you spend money
you're casting a vote for the kind of
world you want
and this is the kind of world that i
want the values the mission everything
that's going on here so that's why i
give you can do that again there's the
box out there on the itty bitty table
you can also give
onlinethetabletx.org you can give online
there if you would like to
lastly you're all standing so you're in
the perfect position for a benediction
and i do believe this is true for each
one of you and i've gone through scenes
and seasons of my life where i've
questioned the truth of this benediction
and the words i say
but i've come through enough to know
that this is rock solid this benediction
these words are true
and i want to impart them to you because
i've lived through them and found them
to be
really really true so if you'd like to
receive these words go ahead and just
open up your palms
and i just pray that they sink into your
mind your bones your body
and go with you out the door into your
weight
[Music]
you are a child of god
you are a child of god this is true on
your best day
and it's especially true on your worst
day
so as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
everything in between
you go with the assurance that you are
loved
you are worthy
and you are accepted just as you are
and go filled with god's holy spirit and
the desire to extend these same gifts of
love and grace and compassion
to everyone you come in contact with
be blessed
have a good night
meet us at hat creek and i also hope to
see you back here next sunday you're
dismissed
[Music]
you